hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey so today we're gonna
watch a trailer for NASA they didn't
know the end of the f king world I'm
pretty sure the f king yeah maybe he's
the sofa king guys really quick I just
want to thank everyone who was a part of
our patreon for the year of 2017 we had
such a great time building our patreon
we didn't expect it to become this much
more personalized so in a way like a
second youtube channel it's more
personal and freeform and off the cuff
mortgage I own interests in the direct
yeah we do a monthly Q&A or it's not
like a bunch of answers we have in a
video we get questions from the patrons
and we turn them into video full-length
video responses we have exclusive patron
our reactions deleted takes and all that
so there's a lot of fun videos over
there would love to have you become a
page from eject today so go check out
our patreon when you get the chance yeah
anyway let's watch this trailer I just
watched this black mirror
beneath me I punch my dad in the face
and stole his car and that felt like a
good place to start
[Music]
but on the ecstasy work seem that
innocent had some issues
[Music]
have you ever seen the ball
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow what that's edgy yes that's a
trailer that's the kind of content that
I would want from a Netflix original
right there yeah you can do whatever you
want and I'm glad to see you are that's
a cool premise that's a really edgy tone
to ride you know yeah a boy serial
killer with traits of a future serial
killer who sets out to kill the girl but
he ends up falling in love with her
along like genuinely falling for her
getting a comfortable evening yeah an
emotion within him but she's also got
this anger side to her too you know
maybe she could be a killer as well me I
hope this movie ends where they both
become killers by they just find love in
the fact they're both serial killers
it's a we ended learning it's a pretty
cool - like a body and collide or
something like that well this is a
series and that's part of well it's a
series no this is serious I was really
surprised cuz this plays like a movie
trailer
yeah and that feels like this could be a
two-hour film yeah what is the structure
of this gonna be like you know what's it
gonna be yeah something or what all the
more intriguing to me I hope it's a
shorter series or you know not even that
it did like a yeah like a six episode
six to eight episode not oh yeah like a
12 or 13 yeah learn from the Punisher
[Laughter]
yeah somewhere there I mean but right
now it looks like a really cool show the
humor looks great it feels like they
found the right tone to head for
something with this dark of comedy what
have something I really like about the
trailer - a lot of times you get dark
comedies and they they have if they
don't find that balance of comedy and
drama yeah this seems like it's gonna be
really funny and having it be funny it
seems like a hard thing to do but that
could also make it special this is a
our tone to ride like you said it's easy
to fall into that category of ah they're
just swearing a whole lot to be raunchy
and they kind of abused the f-word in
the promo
what do you although I feel like but it
works them in a case by case thing and
yeah this is at least this as a trailer
it pretty much worked for me the whole
time the two kids look great yeah they
look like they look great they're both
awkward in their own way but they look
like they have great chemistry well
after seeing that that kid I'll just
shut up and dance which is the name of
his black mirror episode like it seems
like he gets a cast a lot is like kind
of off creep young people actors out
there who you Castle yeah and he's
terrific in that black mayor episode and
this is a totally different kind of
character from that but it's you know
equally I think's probably strange and
well it's Netflix material so I'm sure
they saw him on black mirror and said
let's bring him over for this
yeah totally I'm excited to see this
looks like I wonder where Netflix gets
all the means and money to make all this
stuff because this also looks really
good and like visual and in the montage
moments it looks like there'll be some
violence there too you don't really see
violence in this trailer but in the
montage moments they in debt that when I
hope this is something this is a series
that flirts with violence and
occasionally will show you something is
like shocking or yeah Wow but it doesn't
do it constantly like I wouldn't want
them to like put buckets of blood and
everything like be killing everybody
makes some real impactful violence with
this you know pitch black edgy yeah
comedic material I think this could be
really cool what do you think at the end
of the effing world all right guys well
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification down and make
sure to check out our patreon it like we
said earlier it's like a second youtube
channel a lot of fun different type of
extra video content I'm sure you'll
appreciate it become a patron objected a